[Musique]
kamala harris connaît bien l'univers des
super-héros qui la fascine depuis
l'enfance
l'an dernier elle a même publié un livre
pour enfants sur le sujet les super
héros sont partout un livre dans lequel
elle se dépeint elle-même comme une
héroïne dans le livre les enfants
peuvent faire le serment de super héros
avec ou sans cap pour être un super
héros selon cameron
il faut être altruiste idéaliste et
vaillant dans la ville universitaires de
berkeley où ses parents se sont
rencontrés la célèbre librairie moz ne
cesse de recommander le livre de la
candidate à la vice-présidence qui se
vend ces jours ci comme des petits pains
chauds
[Musique]
camara russe est allé à l'école ici dans
ce quartier très riche et très blanc
situé dans les collines de berkeley si
la petite afro américaine n'a plus
fréquenté cette école privilégiées c'est
qu'à l'époque on avait décidé de
transporter des enfants noirs dans les
écoles des quartiers blancs et des
enfants blancs dans des quartiers noirs
pour favoriser l'intégration et dans la
ville d'auckland où kamal s'agrandit
le racisme est au coeur d'un naufrage
social qui se voit partout dans ces
minerais comme bon nombre de militants
de gauche à oakland cette avocate qui
défend les plus démunis estime que
camara russe est trop à droite
[Musique]
dans la baie de san francisco ou kamala
harris a grandi et où elle a fait
carrière comme procureur général de
l'état puis sénatrice plusieurs estimé
qu'elle assure qu'on pourrait incarner
ce rôle de salvatrice devant ce qui est
perçu par les démocrates comme une
menace conservatrice à maskiot veille de
la course au national
je suis de mercredi qui a défendu bec et
ongles le droit des homosexuels à se
marier affrontera le chrétien
fondamentaliste mike pence en débat